Oi e aí galera que assiste meu canal
hahaha nem sei mais fazer isso aqui
antes de começar o vídeo Eu sempre peço
para clicar em gostei mas eu acho que
vocês precisa de uma pessoa mais
incisiva para vocês clicar porque eu
pedi os vídeos anteriores e vocês então
mais picantes do agora com vocês craque
Neto perde já agora garantiu deixe o seu
like aí que você quer verdade porque
ajuda entregar o vídeo aí eu falo mesmo
os católicos mete louco porque o gato é
louco então já deixa o like aí tem esse
aqui verdade grande Whindersson que foi
o primeiro foi esse negócio de outubro
Então fala o meio de lado ela ok tá aqui
ó Veloso grande Veloso que atende mulher
comprei esse vídeo é o preparei para
vocês um negócio legal que é hoje está
na moda ou Trap né trapp 1000 tem como
colocar auto-tune na minha voz a tocar
nas samba trapé Rua Antônio dá uma
negócio de fermento é então se você
gosta de treper da clique em gostei'
primeiro que eu vou fazer aqui é o md
chefe porque eu acho que ele deixei ele
tem um modo particular de cantar quer
cantando para você no seu ouvido deixa
canta é a melhor pessoa para discutir
porque vai levantar a voz para você ele
vai chegar porque eu tô costurando Tô
costurando aqui com o seu teto que vai
gritando tu baixa bota baiano
e pega Fiat
[Música]
a
moda casos dos fique confortável e
celular Samsung ou Conseguiu dar uma
filmada quase 11 lam estou se comportar
estilo sutiã do relatasse tudo é uma
banho agora para que tô mexendo com ele
quando ele tá gravando que volte meio da
oco parece que alguém dá uma foto
Cadinho contra mas mesmo assim não perde
a postura tá sempre costurada cal no
posto aí aperto até parece que o cara do
tem sentimento máscara tem sentimentos
entender mais entendeu e guerra e a
[Música]
horóscopo Orochi é uma imitação que é
bem rápido
por hoje é só isso disse que era rápido
eu não sei onde tá o lojas em só parte
que horóscopo fala o próprio namoro acho
L7 ol7 Dá para ver que a voz dele assim
tem um pouco de esse do Orochi mas ainda
para ver um carioca e sim eu sou
imitador e o imitador se atenta os
pequenos detalhes E eu então só de você
não falar atrás e falar atrás nós tava
no teu show é bem mais uma vez anos
atrás eu tava no teu show três anos é
por nós tá fazendo salão cozinha não
esqueço quer um
micro para fazer dinheiro mano eu tenho
tão da praça brincar de pula pula
ninguém me segura bem até na chuva da
mesma letra pra gente dá
51 que vi no viu que vindo ele já bota
você para poder aprender a falar o nome
difícil é como eu me sinto conselho mais
o meu que vir para mim a essência do tep
que eu trato para mim aquela música que
você tem que ouvir 10 vezes para você
entender o que está sendo dito porque
parece realmente uma outra língua eu que
vi não faz muito isso porque é muita voz
por cima de vós e termos em inglês e
coisa assim que você não tá dizendo mais
assim como o inglês para mim a vibe é
sempre a metade ela nunca diminuída por
eu não saber o que está sendo dito olha
que legal E aí você tem que dar aquela
traduzida para saber o que que é que ele
tá falando você pode ir para falar a
verdade e falar qualquer coisa ali
dentro e eu por exemplo vou fazer a
propaganda do show que se abalar é menor
de entrada representada que alguém não
tem causou a grande a céu aberto vai ser
pena que eu vou tirar seguidos para o
meu cliente estamos aqui e vou ter mais
feira depois do almoço vídeo que nem ter
e eu preciso da sua mente que
[Música]
eu gosto muito de tudo para falar a
verdade mas não que eu gosto muito do
que eu gosto de gritar eu sou daquele
que canta gritando eu sou eu gosto de
frisar o que você matou
Kuririn eu estou nervoso Nem sempre eu
consigo mais eu gosto do grito eu gosto
dessa do que faz a
e eu acho que dos trevas do que mais
canta com extensão assim muito é o meu é
bom demais mal eu deixei [ __ ]
melhor coisa nosso nordestina quando a
pessoa mulher boa nas coisa é um
[ __ ] não sei porque é porque a
gente tem esse negócio de realmente
pegar as coisas que são uma desgraça e
transformar em coisas boas né Eu sou
[ __ ] vocês são os [ __ ] Todos
nós somos [ __ ] mas não posso
sentir Então vamos lá fazer o eu para
você sempre que eu tô na hora da noite
vira dia
e ela fica tão
o
[Música]
tapete é sobe me chupar passei o dia
pensando nessa
vampira que tem no fundo daquele olho
azul
tudo
mas eu uso óculos no show então nem vai
dar eu posso tirar todo mundo sigo não
dá para mim pegar aí viu que estourou
muito que ao tatatatatatata
tatatatatatata tatatatatatata
Tá eu vou fazer vem para cá vem te amo
vem para cá te odeio vem para cá sabe
falar vem para cá esse tatatatatatata
tatatatatatata
esse negócio apareceu um remix da música
mesmo se chama quinto degrau cara a
menina que canta se chama eu acho legal
porque é no pique do MD chefe também são
músicas que são smr para você assistir
talvez você pode passar a música para
passar aí você vai que a voz é bem suave
eu gosto de ouvir assim cabelo o
grau agora já te fazer passar mal e
sentimentos água superficial relajada
matemática garantido Como assim
aquela fazer hahaha
[Música]
Trio Salvador da Rima também que é puxa
mesmo ó figura só que o salvador da rima
é muito caricato de rosto e a voz também
isso não é trabalho para mim cara tem o
cara que é muito talentoso eu quero
chamado para vocês aqui é em Salvador e
meu parceiro em cima do que certo venho
conteúdo pra vocês aí administração a
gente tem que comentar com ela porque eu
pareço com o Kiko não é Enrico tá
dizendo para casa eu pareço contigo pião
de vida loka to de moletom e acaba o meu
plantão na boca eu vou para o baile
curtir isso Oi Total vi nas novinhas se
tromba com os coxinha eu falo que estão
Mc qualidade do funk aí quando escreve
também tá ligado né velho é realidade
satisfação tá aqui no canal do
Whindersson Nunes Raridade está na voz
da cantora para vocês aqui uma música
Mulekada aí a visão do que a vida
própria loja que vai soltar o bicho pra
gente tem que o Raridade
porque hoje estamos aqui juntos para
conscientização e
e
ficou dodoi chocolate EA ilusão postei
só todos e mais poderoso
vários vai vamos já tá que acabou na já
tá lotada de curioso último de hoje
porque vocês vão poder pedir nos
comentários quem mais eu posso imitar já
sei que cês vão pedir várias pessoas que
vocês vão vídeo eu já sei mas eu prefiro
que você digite para eu ler tem certeza
então bota aqui embaixo nos comentários
que você quer porque por último eu vou
fazer ele mais esperado eu hahaha sabe o
que é que vai acontecer com o índia ele
vai cantar no Rock in Rio 4 de setembro
no palco Supernova no Rock in Rio que
horas eu não sei também tô aprendendo
ainda como é ser um traço Qual que é a
característica do leasing de colocar as
coisas que ninguém pensa por exemplo
nesta no grupo da roça dois eu coloquei
como que se faz farinha de tapioca é
porque é da vivência do índio
transporta-se para o índio né onde que
você vai cantar vibrando pulando lá no
Rock in Rio junto comigo eu tô sempre
com serial o meu burro tem que contar
com a sorte tem olhou para olhar para
que move tome tento sempre assim do meu
carro Viajando o mundo e caçando os
malote estão sempre vendo que porque
mora ela quer saber quanto eu ganho por
mês aqui partes o que eu pego numa
história porque eram perfeito Cangaço no
trampo para poder essa diferença de me
para você tiro do Papel faça acontecer
Toda Toda Então tira os pés do chão e o
caso ser tão acessível
tática fábrica de macaxeira
[Música]
realidade
mágica
não tira os pés do chão chão
[Música]
o de hoje foi esse eu estou saindo em
turnê pelo Brasil então se você quer
assistir o meu Isso não é um curso para
mim o melhor de todos os links na
descrição do vídeo não vai esquecer do
dia quatro de setembro tem um Indy no
palco Supernova do Rock in Rio quero
você lá que eu tô indo comigo todas as
músicas leu
Não esquece de clicar em gostei hahaha
tô esperando o seu gostei aqui em que
não esquece de comentar o nome de quem
você quer que eu emitir no próximo vídeo
que estamos gravando hoje é o primeiro
vídeo na cultura e criativa depois eu
vou mostrar pra vocês e também está
rolando aí o meu curso hahaha para você
ser mais interessante chamar mais gente
aí pela internet para você tamo junto é
nóis fazer
assim estão tudo na descrição e